all right so some
tactical contextualization
so
what the tactics the iron bar the throws
the energetic throws the
non-contestation
etc
that are make up your kihon wasa so
they're within your kihon waza
they assume what we call asocial
violence and asocial violence is marked
by territoriality
and
physiologically speaking
i don't i'm gonna take his space people
don't realize they're doing this okay
they're just aggressive and they're
angry
all right but we're looking at it
structurally so
uh this is not what angry people do
angry people aggressive people
will either consciously or
subconsciously take over where he's
standing
territorial
and we mark that
in terms of geometry with what we're
calling spinal displacement i take my
spine and i stand and displace his spine
from where it's standing
all of your
aikido
kihon waza tactics assume
asocial
violence is occurring that's the context
for it okay so uh let's say
he's gonna do a two-hand push
but
social violence so he's not trying to
displace me he's just trying to
get my ego going do you see
so i try to do uh kokunage from there
and you're not gonna get it
but he does the same push with the
spinal displacement and you'll get
all of all your ikea kihon
assuming asocial
tactical content
this is why
it is not smart first of all to define
the art
by
a self-defense situation it that doesn't
make sense okay
or to define the art by only its keyhole
and equally it does not make sense
that i try to figure out a way to do the
tactics within kihon for social violence
so he does that push and like okay how
do i get cookie nugget
that is dumb
say likewise a jab
the jab has no spinal displacement
so it makes no sense to figure out how
to get kotagash on the jab makes no
sense you don't understand the key one
all right
there's something else peculiar to
asocial violence
because he's practicing territoriality
the overwhelming majority of people
will use their legs to transport their
spine
they will not use their legs
in a way i'll do it
to cover the bridging of their gap
overwhelmingly people will use their
aggression their speed their surprise
their violence and action
to make safe
the bridging of the gap make safe
against what makes sense against
counter-strikes boom
they will not
do feeler strikes boom or bridging
so
you're now in a different context
you're going to have to
be able to navigate this context okay
so in order to learn how to navigate the
context in terms of defense i have to
know how to do the context so i can
train him and he can train me okay
so the one we're looking for
today
is attacking the closest target to me
that's the leg
i'm going to use that as my bridging
okay
so when i bridge my goal is to get back
to asocial violence it is not
to pepper him and come out i'm not here
to win this thing in terms of points i'm
here to kill him or defeat him that's
what i'm here for
so it makes no sense to throw this light
it makes no sense to throw it in a way
that i can't counter continue my attack
and when i throw the attack it's not a
whole other different kind of technique
so for example here i am in kihon he's
pushing and that energy is being
grounded and that's the energy that i
project out
same thing on the throw who won't pop
i take his resistance of his mass into
the foot
so don't start
changing arcs
same way i do those throws
it's the same way i take this energy
here let go and i do the same thing
on his chest foot boom
is the same way i throw my hand
it's in this foot
i'm not here
and relying on different engines like
hip rotation it goes in the foot
so you're going to feel
your energy your mass grounded you're
going to feel his energy his past keep
it grounded
so you're not here
coming up on your heel
this energy goes through boom
boom
so i'm not kicking them hard but i i
want to feel the resistance of his mass
the target and that
goes into the ground
and now i'm in the back
if you want
take your body
[Music]
okay let's work it
bridgey
go
okay so i want to repeat the point
in aikido it's always internal it's
always internal which means energy goes
through my body that's what makes it
internal and i project it onto a greater
mass there's a rebound and that's what i
use to displace his mass with okay the
rebounding energy
so
i i don't want to start going
like that's a kind of energy you see i
have a gravitational
drop
i also don't want to go back to
just my hip rotation
that's not what i'm doing
i'm going to send all my energy my
moving energy my gravitational pull of
my mass into that foot
the same way yes it's fast but that's
the skill it doesn't require time you're
not doing it if you need a lot of time
to get it set up
when i hit that's now energy that goes
into that foot
and that's what allows the displacement
so i do the kick
and
i'm going to kick through
i want i don't want that leg to be there
into this foot is where i'm
concentrating
so he's back off the bag
and i can't sit here and kick him all
day long
so i'm going to slow it down which is
possible
we'll displace
here
what i'm looking for
is that tilt
that's the same tilt you set up so
we did this technique there's the tilt
right there we came in
that's what makes the base attackable
so boom engine oh break it
[Music]
right there
you can hide it too in your face and
faint facing faith
but watch how my hands are reaching for
things you see
and when you get to the throw
it's not
bending backwards
it's lock his body
so you're going to be grounding you take
the energy of his mass
your mask and put it on the next foot
and lock his body you're not trying to
throw his head up here his whole body
his whole body right from your whole
body that's the throat
there's no need to take the head you're
taking that
there's more need
to keep the things checked
you already got the head in the kick
make sure you're locking the body
so in terms of maximum efficiency
your throws are going to
have a greater effect on his person and
his ability to fight then your strikes
okay
so you would never where you could throw
you would never strike okay
so when you're in this technique and we
can make it a little more alive okay so
he might be the one that moves into me
oh and then i have it
let's get to the throw part oh here
you're not hitting him like wrestling
pro wrestling
your arm is here and now you seek the
body lock okay so i'm not hitting him
and i hope he knocks down if i hit him
he might be able to take the blow
do you see he might be able to take the
blow
i want to continue the kazushi that i
started
this thing
i'm going to turn his body
with the body lock
i'm going slowly so you can see
i want the planet to hit up
so don't
try to knock him down
continue this opening
don't try to hit you in here
no
contact
throw
not impact
go
okay
so if you study if you guys and i highly
um recommend it okay
you should you should look
at
what are other arts doing what's their
discourse what's their understanding
okay but when you look at it
you look at it
to plug it back into
your ikea
okay
so if you look at
the r that openly call themselves
internal arts so aikido is not wonderful
not of most people
most people
do not say that okay
and out of those that do say it they do
not have the same understanding of
internal as the other arts that openly
call themselves this is an internal art
okay
the process
is
simplified as i understand it as i have
put it before you okay because those
other arts get very very complicated
there's cultural reasons why they do
they're not practical reasons they're
cultural reasons and so i highly
recommend you do not get lost in them so
even since they had
cultural reasons that over complicated
things so all his correspondences for
example okay
mystical traditions always had
correspondences if you go throughout
history and you look at a mystical
tradition and mystical does not mean woo
mystical does not mean uh imaginary or
the opiate of the masses that is modern
man's
rhetoric
to justify his own culture
today
you have to denounce the culture of the
past so you make a straw man argument
out of it
and then you gotta pretend that you're
reinventing the wheel like flow state
and all this other kind of crap
mindfulness all that other [\h__\h] okay
but every time you reinvent the wheel as
a side note here it's always a cracking
wheel why don't you just stick to the
original cultural system that developed
the technology and you're going to be
better off okay
so even though most says they had all
these correspondences this fire water uh
directions of the of the
compass uh elements and it just goes on
and on and on
the mystical tradition is ultimately
about
a reconciling of all those
correspondences so it is immediately
futile
and a waste of time to get involved with
infinite number of correspondences
is there's a cultural reason why they do
that
there's not a practical reason meaning
those infinite correspondences will not
help me gain a mystical experience which
is a reconciliation of the subject
object dichotomy how i experience my
world
having an infinite number of
correspondences and remembering them is
not going to help me gain that skill
so likewise when you look at the
internal arts
you're going to see the same kind of
cultural discursive development and you
will get lost in it
so i have given you a simple thing the
process is
energy passes through me you have to
understand that i must become
a vessel i must become empty the energy
passes through me this is the heart
of non-contestation
so he pushes and you move it out of the
way is not it is a non-contestation but
it's not really the heart of
non-contestation
the heart of non-contestation is this
energy is going through me it's going to
the ground my arm can stay at apparently
weird angles do you see weird angles my
arm can stay at weird angles this this i
try to do this externally won't work but
if i just let that energy push into me
the right angle is fine and you can come
back from it just keep pushing
into the ground you see so he's not
really pushing into the lever
and so i don't really over strain
the inner deltoid and it becomes
possible
that's non-contestation
so
the energy must pass through me to do
that i must become an empty vessel and
that is the overlap between the physical
techniques and the spiritual techniques
because in the same way that energy is
passing through me
due to my emptying of self
this opens the door for
what various mystical traditions we'll
call the divine god grace
what we moderns micah well now there's
no more subject there's no more object
you're in the mystical experience at a
physiological level because there's no
separation of body mind
they're the same
so i wouldn't get caught up in all the
different
qi or all the different gene or
all the yin yang correspondences as you
look at the internal arts
so
you're looking for this emptying of self
that means his energy goes through me
to use it martially
his energy goes through me
and i redirect it internally into a
greater mass
than the property of the greater mass
which is often the planet
is going to displace the energy that i
sent down because it's greater mass so
it will reflect it or rebound it
back into my person because i'm empty
it'll go back into my person
and then i can aim it
and do different things with it but
whose energy was it it was his energy
going through me hitting a greater mass
it's that same energy
but it's not just his energy there's
also the energy of my mass the
gravitational pull on my mass the
movement of my mass through space all
that has to
pass through me to the greater mass to
get the reflection or the deflection or
the rebound
so if i'm doing this drill
and he's pushing
i am just going to static make it go
down down
let's begin our beginner level learn to
empty yourself
and let it go down to the ground
then what i do is okay well it went down
now get the rebounding energy and learn
to let it back up you let that energy
back in let it come back out so we'll
pop
pull
and the harder it pushes boom the more
immediate the effect the energy goes it
goes boom it's greater and faster okay
well
that same energy can be done
in this case it's in a pushing way
in coming back towards me so here's his
mass
and
as i try to pull him forward
that's more gravity against me well i
send that down to the ground and you can
get
that side of the equation
so for simplicity state i don't give it
all the different gins that the internal
arts would give it this one who is
called cube and this one
energy that is
is coq and the energy that adheres from
communes is ikey do you understand
this here is a drill though
clearly it's a drill because partially
no one should be grabbing me and i don't
know why i'm sitting here so if you
don't understand drilling
and you think to some
martial context you're lost you're not
going to get it
so here so far
i have a kit
and i have a bridging technique you see
i'm leaving the drilling rule and i'm
starting to enter application you see
that okay
i don't want to change the engines that
i use you understand okay so i'm not
going to go to hip rotation just like
i'm not going to go to uh here i'm not
going to go to hip rotation here
that's not what i'm doing
this mass is being pushed down
my mass is being pushed down
my mass is moving
all that is energy all that energy goes
into the ground vector which means so it
can rebound off the greater mass of the
planet you understand okay
when i do this
in drilling it's done slowly you see
it's done slowly
for the purposes
of prolonging the cultivation field
but if you think you're going to have
that much time in application you're
crazy you're dreaming okay
which means i need to be able to do it
quickly like
all this energy whoa all that mass
that's got to go into that foot not like
this
do you see
it's got to be quick
quick
not here
same thing on the kick
it can't be i'm not using hip rotation
i'm going to use this
[Music]
now this brings up something else
my dynamic
i have the time space
for the kick
and i have the time space
for the body locking me
too far
too out
in
too far in
so
he's a little more dynamic now
i move boom
right now boom same thing
don't jab yourself
watch what you might have to do
maybe you got to go out
don't get stuck
ground
my
mind
[Music]
don't get chilled don't be out of range
go
so he's drilling this stuff he's going
to be the the initiator now so he's
doing his face and face
oh
and he's coming in what is this
spinal displacement
okay
so first
non-contestation
on the kick
just like uh
he's pushing
and get out of the way to push
okay
so his kick is round
move off the circle
up the circle reach out and absorb just
like your swords sword reaches out he
goes
boom
[Music]
he's going to keep doing his thing right
you're going to see keep closing
it comes there it is
[Music]
you're going to feel this pressure
oh you're supposed to heal spiral
okay there's something to understand as
you move from cultivation drills to
application another thing it's very very
important this jacks up by keo people
all the time okay
let's look let's pay attention to the
early
yoga skills okay he's pushing in me
right i need him to push into me i need
his force to come into me that's the
whole point of the internal skills
this this is not it
you see that
okay
likewise he's doing his thing
oh i need that
so you're not going here
you see that
one
it won't be internal
and two
it's not that it's impossible you the
only way you can do that is you know
what's coming okay
your sensations your martial sensations
are through feeling
not through my intellect you get it so
when he goes
whoa oh crap that's what you're going to
feel okay so i've had a lot of
ikea people
your mind is wrong you don't you're
[\h__\h] back in technique land you're
back in keyhole it's not wrong it's not
wrong because his energy is going
through me i'm not contesting it just
because i'm close to him it's not i'm
not contesting it energy is going
through me
so as he goes
who let him push he's gonna be the one
to tell you where to go
i want you to watch what my my is doing
here
watch how much closer i am to him
[Music]
see that difference
just because i'm close
doesn't mean i'm contesting equally just
because i'm far
does not mean i'm not contesting
non-contestation is an internal aspect
hey so uh
say it out loud uh go which uh
internal skill is that
i keep yeah so that's your convenience
skill
[Music]
that means that energy
is just up this way
you're not just going like this
well you're not bracing for impact
your energy is flowing through you
and we go on
don't have your hands on guard your
workspace here oh yeah he's pushing
push
which
energy
cook you yeah okay so it's holding this
separate do you see so i don't
want to get out of the way
this energy goes into the ground
it's very relaxed
and by choice
i
yield i have this body
okay
i have this body
back you need me
you're trying to do your knees okay
and now i go into the in space
but that initial energy
is what i'm going to project
on whatever foot i find
often in your keyhole it's the back foot
but in fighting it's whatever is in
contact with the greater mass okay so
i go
it might be the back foot
but depending on what's happening
it might be the front foot so i'm on
this foot push
push
i'm on this foot
and that might be the one
that i end up doing okay you're all just
letting it go through you and finding
the greater mass
so
boom push push push push push push i
yield i load that energy
and this is a cokey projection
it's not a momentum throat coq
projection
okay let's go